[Music]
how do you feel after tonight how
confident are you I feel I feel a lot of
things ultimately I feel like I did my
best I had some some good parts and not
so good parts but you know I think I
tried my hardest I'm proud of what I did
and and you know I'm confident that I
got good folks behind me that I saw when
I went back home that her behind me and
supportive of me no matter what you know
and I'm just crossing my fingers and
hoping that I can win American Idol so
Katy did say that the first chunk of
performances was a quote disaster what
was going through your mind when you
heard that you know I kind of agree with
her in some ways you know I this is that
everything's happened so quick it's one
thing when we're asked to learn songs
that we've heard before it's a whole
other thing when we got a to learn the
song make it our own do it in the studio
figure out how we're gonna do it on
stage you know I think I think everybody
did well I think Maddie did excellent
with her original song in particular and
you know I feel like I did all right you
know it's always hard starting off the
show and whatnot but I did the best I
could and that's all I can ever try to
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]